nos dicen que leo multiplico dos números
y obtuvo un producto par cuáles de las
siguientes opciones podrían ser
verdaderas aquí dice elige dos
respuestas pausa el vídeo y trata de
averiguar cuáles de estas opciones
podrían ser verdaderas bien hagamos esto
juntos y tenemos que pensar en lo que
podría ser verdad no tienen que ser
ciertas solo tienen que ser posibles muy
bien ahora es posible que ambos números
eran pares puedes multiplicar los
números pares y obtener un producto par
bueno claro que sí y puedo imaginar
ejemplos de eso si multiplicas dos por
cuatro lo que es igual a ocho tienes un
número par por un número par que te da
un número par de hecho en general cuando
multiplicas los números pares obtendrás
un producto par y entonces esto
definitivamente podría ser verdad ambos
números eran impares puede ser que
recuerdes que un número impar por un
número impar siempre será impar o puedes
ver algunos ejemplos y estar seguro de
que ese es el caso si multiplicas 3 por
es igual a 15 un número impar por un
número impar es igual a un número impar
si multiplica 7 por 9 obtienes 63 una
vez más un número impar por un número
impar es igual a otro número impar
entonces no hay forma de que puedas
multiplicar los números impares y
obtener un producto par así que
descartamos esta un número era par y el
otro número era impar bueno pensemos en
lo que sucede cuando multiplicas un
número par por un número impar si
multiplico dos por tres es igual a 6 así
que tienes un par solo pondré una p aquí
por un impar es igual a un par por lo
tanto las dos formas en que puedes
obtener un producto par es si
multiplicas un número par por otro
número par o un número par por un impar
esencialmente un número par multiplicado
por un número par o por un impar te dará
como resultado un producto par hagamos
otro ejemplo
se nos pregunta en cuál de las
siguientes opciones se obtiene un
producto par dice una vez más elige dos
respuestas así que vuelva a pausar el
vídeo y trata de resolverlo muy bien 8
585 es lo mismo que 8 por 5 y esta es
una situación en la que estamos
multiplicando un par de de par por un
impar ya hemos dicho que nos va a dar
como resultado un producto par ni
siquiera tienes que saber que 8 por 5 es
40 que es un número par tenemos un
número par multiplicado por un número
impar lo que nos dará como resultado un
producto par así que esto
definitivamente nos dará un producto
para un número impar multiplicado por un
número par bueno ya hemos hablado de eso
cualquier número par o impar
multiplicado por un número par te va a
dar como resultado un número par así que
podemos rellenar eso y luego 5 por 3
tiene su número impar multiplicado por
un número impar que te dará como
resultado un número impar incluso si no
supieras que el resultado
hacer 15 sabrías que un número impar
multiplicado por otro número impar
siempre te dará como resultado un
producto impar no un producto par así
que elegiremos estas dos opciones